it's time for roses and road day guys
this glass Rose a mouthful just like
part one of this week's to night event
was packed full of drama you so be
careful just like Rachel had to be with
Jack and I ride a hope K we should get
along we should be perfect for each
other
Wow let's dive in I was so pleased with
this episode because usually when it's a
two-night event night one's a little
bland I do little pal but night one was
pow okay also yes everybody bachelor in
paradise is back in production thank you
Jesus
right at the top good episode so you
guys might have heard of Monty Python's
of The Life of Brian you all got to work
it out for yourself well this was the
night of Brian Brian was saying all the
right things he was telling Rachel that
they're a perfect match I thought about
you know ones there are simple solutions
I just think we're perfect match but
they are so good together every single
time I see you it's just a progress that
he was going to tell her exactly how he
felt and Rachel doesn't like to play
game Brian is not playing games Brian is
like sit down in my class read my
textbook it's a love story of me and you
fairy tale Wow I'm not playing game
right you just say fairy tale I think it
is a fairy tale
37 old chiropractors in Illinois engage
you forgot because you had this page
it's easy to forget this episode I saw
the truth behind Brian and I see where
Rachel likes him be persistent it's
Keith we have the cute little with Brian
and then we had a one-on-one with Jack
you've heard of the movie Jack with
Robin Williams if the right kid who was
unusual oh no this Jack was too okay
no Jack and Rachel I don't know what
they did I just remember Jack there for
Rachel I'll try to imitate it for you
now okay
so Jack asked if he was crazy it's crazy
but it's crazy and then he said he knows
Rachel's dad really well I feel like I
get him but and he just wouldn't stop
talking about how close they were
getting I don't necessarily feel closer
to him and Rachel very diplomatically
said I knew that didn't sound great and
then she said well bye jack but he's in
paradise so we'll get another chance to
see this
and Jack tried to kiss Rachel but she
was like I'm sick I'm sick okay one more
time for your nightmares my hair is
making it weirder it's like a Phantom of
the Opera got him oh the candy and leaf
you'd return drink every time Kenny
called Lee a snake
this episode disingenuous snake yeah
he's reptilian sliver from from place to
place
Kenny literally mind a snake mind that
Lee with a snake during the roaster is
not something around there's one thing I
like about Kenny I think because he's
like a semi pro wrestler he comes up
with a lot of really fun phrases when
he's insulting Lee like you can't handle
this realness and it you would central
and tickle monster man was sent home but
we know at least we'll see Iggy and
parrot twice bachelor and parrot twice
enjoyed everybody can't wait airing this
summer hopefully I don't know I don't
know what's got anyone I'm excited about
it okay oh and now we're in Norway at a
hotel named the TARDIS a dandy kommen :
park hotel here in Oslo Norway that was
being one line of the episode we're
still at that stage where each episode
kind of focuses on a different person
like it keep them interesting and how
between know who these people are
because I still forget cuz I saw a lot
of them back to the night of Brian so
Brian gets a one-on-one mmm
and when I say ah I mean literally ah
murder because their one-on-one was them
rappelling down the side of some kind of
mountain building and it looked so scary
and Brian was like they're not scared
I'm up here
ah I was like oh if you're a bird I'm a
bird sheera bird on the moon and I'm
like if only we could fly get away from
here
good lord but you guys this is when I
fell for Brian because as we will
rappelling down the mountain building
mountain from space Brian called her
babe and then he wanted it kids and I
just love when they call each other babe
because it's so intimate and real some
guys when they do this weird but with
Brian it wasn't and then we heard a lot
of kissing noise drinking scare kissing
noise oh and Brian and Rachel are this
really amazing dinner where Rachel
proved once again why we loved her he
said that she did not blossom until
college and so I didn't know how to take
it I wasn't ready for it attorneys about
that I literally say that phrase I
always say I didn't blossom until
college Rachel I won't you do I found
like Jack and we are going to be playing
a popular European sport handball oh
then we had handball why I don't know
Rachel said it was a well-known European
sports I would have to google it but I
didn't care enough but in google it so I
don't know what it is but the guys were
these outfits which works great handball
was on the ball
and Peter was looking good and Peter was
wrong Rachel around and nobody was
complaining about that okay okay oh and
we'll got a moment I love will you guys
will have been the unsung hero voice of
reason on this show amidst all the
Kenyan League garbage and we'll finally
got a rose and Rachel called him Michael
Jordan welfare Bachelor I really mean
this either Peter for Bachelor if he
doesn't get picks and she picks science
or will for Bachelor
if she doesn't if she picks Peter and I
love will I love will
Oh back to the house and now the night
of Peter by Brian so we're reminded of
how much Rachel loves Peter who she's
like Peter notices things that no one
else's and when I'm with Peter he is
very lasered into me which says a lot
and then Peter kisses her and then
Rachel makes a move do you want to cover
it in the hot tub what this yes Rachel
yes she's like why don't we cover this
in the hot tub why don't we take a
meeting in the hot tub why don't we have
the conference call in the hot tub why
don't we look over your PowerPoint in
the hot tub why don't we go over the
you're in the hot tub yes from the law
firm of Lindsay Lindsay and Lindsay I'll
take it
the Peter nature and lots of we got a
lot of great zoom I'm Peter Pan and I
don't know if they made them reshoot
that they say did great callbacks or
producers great call oh but will got the
rose and Peter was sad and I don't blame
Peter because he worked hard on that
date you saw the hand he was working
hard so Peter does gotta keep people
guessing you know so will got the Rose
oh and now we know what sad Peter looks
like sad Peter where's the hoodie he's
like I'm not doing my hair I'm sad feet
by the way I exclusively interviewed
Peter and if you want to check out the
interview so ready it's online calm he
explains his connection with Rachel and
also talks about whether he'd be the
bachelor so Lee is still a snake
[Music]
we go to Lee in Chinese two-on-one and
it's in the wood because leaves a snake
and snakes are outdoor and bbc1 ones are
always in remote area so the people can
be left to be great I'll take it out of
mine oh and there's a lot of debate
about of Vance Lee says that Kenny
pushed him out of a van and pulled him
out of a van and Rachel sells Jenny's at
least as he pushed him out of a van and
Penny says that never happened it's 100%
cause there was never a van she's lying
to you we roll the clip these people get
everything on pills will the van click
this shortstack southern piece of
garbage
ah no Kenny continues to be creative
with his insults Oh God
how will we be as creative with his
fists we won't find out until tomorrow
night everybody Tuesday night is the
conclusion of the bachelor to night of
men we will not be doing a roses in row
say for Tuesday night however on Tuesday
morning we will be at the EP Facebook
page with a Facebook live so check that
out
and also please of course let me know
your thoughts who are you loving Peter
Brian
Oh Peter 14 oh I'm still interesting we
barely saw him this episode except for
when he couldn't pronounce the hotel
name and a coma : Park Hotel thank you
so much for watching everyone
love you guys please subscribe to et on
YouTube like us on Facebook follow me on
Twitter and Instagram and have a great
night I still have so much Rosie left
it's Rosie from last week if anyone
knows how long wine stays wine I'd love
to know I'd love to know
I'm gonna stop me
there's likely by let me pull up man
ultra knows what's my code I got the
turret - sueded sueded sueded Pizza
hands and beepers and when up
[Music]